[ __ ] oops to this video playing swap
from Germany the national master Miller
maybe can't do something else made just
for a change play the play the London
system not the most dangerous of
openings but good to have some some
variety hmm I can i play now I just let
just develop I thought 95 maybe would be
an idea can still play and f4 if he
allows me to do that I think 97 is a
decent plan here 97 two and five it's
not doing that ok let's continue so I
have a sort of stonewalled but with the
bishop not being incarcerated I wonder
my special page for I can still play
Knight f5 I guess interesting Bishop h4
night f5 takes a 5 EF Bishop f6 Queen f6
97 wins the exchange but it's not clear
after night our Tarquini 7 from not
clear at all and if if he goes for GF
with this triple pawn can play night to
h4 and stuff not sure absolutely not
sure maybe I'm just falling into a very
well-known positional trap
be possible I wonder can i play Quincy
to first attacking f5 g6 not sure that
he wants to play g6 hmm
g6 takes 97 and it looks at the dance
that's a bit better about bit more
interesting let's say not sure how we
protect that five now a g6 I think I
really can take take f6 greene takes 97
Queenie 78 x f8 23 check king h1 rook
takes a Phaedra ke one and I'm trapping
the Queen this was too quick them I
should look at it later it's difficult
projects their porn
Bishop a six I just play hmm play what
exactly look F to maybe look f3 now or
to f3 yeah to f3 is better protecting
III so that g6 it's not really possible
however in general this winning of this
winner of the exchange is not not
totally clear still difficult for him to
to play something else or I can just
give up the pawn and claim compensation
on the light squares maybe maybe this is
possible he's taking it's taking its
sweet time here it's definitely critical
this position
yeah I'm not sure how we can claim
compensation on the Ducks on the light
squares after Corey Taylor five it's
also an important pawn missing in black
structure this is a real problem it's
not like just the pawn but it's an
important pawn it's not moving is this
may be a connection issue let's let's
check annual he's connected okay now he
went when to move okay I guess I'll take
it not not second-guessing myself him
haha so he's content with with some sort
of endgame mm-hmm power down endgame
yeah wonder rabbit the problem is if I
go Queen d3 my play 94 that's not really
not really fantastic okay Bishop a six
probably activate things just playing a
couple of strengthening news not not
sure yet how to how to set up here maybe
you can just take you five I can take
with the f pawn maybe
okay I take with the deep on itv4 takes
takes he would play the I can play the
Bishop to d3 but i can't play mine to d6
as well f takes maybe 94 ok let's take
with this but Bishop here is not really
but really helping me much I guess I can
also play this type of move group the
ages what I want to prevent not letting
him come to the D file well that's a
that's debatable weakening weakening the
dark squares even more
h4 h5 Luke h2
yeah Luke g7 as a move I want to prevent
now okay let's get ahead rook age 28 h 5
is coming
best you can do is exchange yeah and now
i can play here and invade on the d file
is not quick enough to get it to d3 and
may behave h5 was still stronger
actually as crook g6e can play king f7
okay so this wasn't wasn't so precise
okay it's nevertheless of course quite
good for white but I could have played
could have played much better yeah h5
was was a lot stronger and ce4 i miss c4
i missed c4
time warning will get and rook t7 now I
think try to play with rookie ATM maybe
this is so still something check of
course I I could I could have played it
better Bishop f1 Jackie this was a
chance for black sheep on I guess I
guess this one too to have black so I
didn't really look at the time I was
winning on time anyway I'm still trying
to play chess even with a little time
yeah I missed I missed some some good
things here looked it to us I mean h5 is
just much stronger it's much stronger I
i was thinking care that you always feel
tempted to use the open file but in this
case it does not net net me so much this
is just stronger why does widest m
getting and the age file open he
probably has to do something like this
when i get when i get this in yeah wide
wide win CM it was quite quite
surprising that an IT force better here
it seems that this disinfect was
problematic yes um g6 maybe really the
way to go I wasn't I wasn't totally sure
in the game I had this variation
calculated who is seven takes takes
takes takes and I trap the Queen which
is not forced of course but a line that
needs to be reckoned with
the question is in fact if something
like that is maybe maybe possible black
get some some nice activity trapping my
night this is just plus one according to
the comp weird weird position really
weird okay it still seems to be good for
wide the question is can you give it up
some songs probably not okay but this
this is of course it's just better for
white only question is how much better
is it ok age three and went here and now
we decided to go for this evidence must
be must be very good for wide really I
have the eye control d8 very important
and g6 is a strange rules I mean I'm not
sure our f5 it's not really a threat at
the moment i believe and i don't i don't
think it's a good idea to give me f6 in
addition to everything else and here
yeah this is just plus to win winning
winning basically and now h5 is much
stronger this this keeps an edge but
it's not it's probably adhere i missed
c4 of course yeah i just played this far
too quickly routine move but c4 is much
better of course he cannot take a check
winning and this means he must put the
bishop back to e8 and only then i do
continue which obviously must must gain
something must have gained something
from me now i can can try to try to
improve my position some some way for
example to improve could be king g 3 +
f5 to invade with the king or h5 takes
f5 this this also is a good idea and
look at this
this could be a good idea yeah that's
quite strong using using the pawn power
of this this looks decisive ready or if
you look at this something like this and
then he six yeah white white should win
this end game with what's see for this
is this was bad it keeps it keeps an
advantage but it's not as clear and
attack here but here I thought maybe he
can play a play Bishop Bishop here rook
g2 maybe this is a draw yeah yeah I
would have screwed up I had screwed up
here here this is a very strong strong
threat check I can I can also cause
always force the draw this is a cuteness
yeah that's a perpetual check check
check check check check from here so I
really made a mistake them channel now
I'm winning again on the clock and and
on position okay thanks for watching